hey guys today we're going to talk about
whether Jon Snow can ride dragons or not
now that we know for sure who Jon Snow's
parents are in the TV show Game of
Thrones what does it all really mean a
lot of people have been asking about
whether he has a right to claim the Iron
Throne or not but I don't think that's
the most interesting question that we
have to think about Jon's character has
never been painted as a King type or a
power-hungry person he was hesitant to
take the Lord Commander position when it
came up and personality was he's much
more like Ned you know Honorable Ned
Stark who raised him if we think about
the people who have gone after power in
the show so far like Tywin and Cersei
Lannister Renly Baratheon Margaery
Tyrell Littlefinger and so on it seems
like pretty apparent that John is a
different type of individual that makes
me think that a different question is
probably what we should be thinking
about now that we know who his parents
are for sure since his father is Rhaegar
Targaryen the older brother of Daenerys
who don't forget just hatched three
dragons you know I wonder if this means
that Jon Snow can ride one of them we
could take the easy way out here and
just say yeah you know he has Targaryen
blood so sure why not he's a dragon
rider but you know there's actually a
lot of there's we actually know a lot of
history about who's mounted dragons and
you know who hasn't been able to so you
know just saying that he's Targaryen
which you know Targaryen Tsar blood of
the dragon doesn't mean that he's
actually able to bond with the dragon we
know a lot of history about the
Targaryen because of the you know from
the books the book series and you know
with the addition of the world of Ice
and Fire and so let's not forget all the
dragons died off before Daenerys came
along she was able to hatch three eggs
and nobody had done that for a really
long time so the important part here is
that she has claimed Rogan
she's dragons Rider but that leaves the
other two weapons of mass destruction
who could be claimed but you know it's
just not not anyone can just become a
dragon rider
dragons are native to the continent of
Essos and it is said the first dragons
came from the east from the shadow lands
beyond - I and islands of the Jade sea
regardless of their exact origin direct
it's known the Dragons populated most of
the known world and ages past at its
apex valaria was the greatest city in
the known world the center of
civilization within the shining walls to
school rival houses vied for power and
glory in court and council rising and
falling in an endless subtle off savage
struggle for dominance the Targaryens
were far from the most powerful the
dragon lords and their arrival saw their
flight to Dragonstone as an act of
surrender as cowardice but lowered a
nurse maiden daughter Danny's known
forever afterward as Danny's the dreamer
had foreseen the destruction of valaria
by fire and when the doom came 12 years
later the Targaryen were the only dragon
Lords to survive according to this
passage from the world of Ice and Fire
there were 40 Dragon Lord families in
the blaring freehold and that's well
that's a lot of dragons and Dragon
Riders if you're not familiar with the
history outside of Westeros there's too
much of it to get into and for the like
for this video but what is important is
that the tar games were the last
remaining family that had dragons and
could ride them this brings a
interesting point to think about when
you have 40 houses of dragons there's a
sense of mutually assured destruction
that keeps things somewhat in check when
you only have one family with dragons it
makes him unbelievably powerful about
125 years after the dueling doom of
Valyria began Aegon the first and his
sister wives
Visenya and Rainey's used their dragons
to conquer six out of the seven kingdoms
in Westeros in old town at the starry
cept Aegon was anointed king of the
Andals the Rhoyne are and the first men
lord of the Seven Kingdoms and protector
of the realm he took all the swords of
his defeated enemies and forged them
into what we know as the Iron Throne
time and history is now marked BC and AC
for before and after the conquest his r
and his reign began when he was anointed
in one a sea
from this point the targaryen heirs
occupied the iron throne until robbers
for rebellion in 282 AC their dragons
died long before that though when King
Viserys the first Targaryen dies in 129
a civil war breaks out that becomes
known as the dance of the Dragons his
wife the Queen refused to follow his
wishes to have his daughter succeed him
and instead installed her own son as
king this led to a bloodbath that killed
off most of the remaining Targaryen
dragons by 153 AC the last dragon dies
and even theirs even though they're
still dragon eggs in the world no one is
able to hatch them for about 150 years
there are no living dragons in Westeros
and none of the eggs hatch until then
Daenerys comes along and hatches hers in
299 HC so that's a lot of history but
just bear with me because we're almost
there and the actual history is really
important because nothing happens in
this series or this world throughout
without a reason so it's never clearly
explained why some people have the
ability to bomb with dragons and some
don't this is because it doesn't appear
that anyone actually really knows for
sure it is known that plenty of people
have died and have been killed trying to
mount dragons though and the dragons
only bond with one rider at a time in
the case of Aegon he rode balerion the
black dread while his sister's rode
Veigar and MARAC seized all three
siblings were Dragon Riders but they
never rode each other's mounts dragons
generally live longer than people though
so once they're rotted once a rider dies
they can take another rider
we know that the Targaryens were the
last dragon Lords to survive the doom of
Valyria
but having Targaryen blood isn't a
guarantee that you'll be able to ride a
dragon there are many theories about why
their blood is special and why it makes
them Dragon Riders but they don't even
really know for sure in any case they
often marry brother to sister to try to
keep the bloodline pure regardless there
were still plenty of Targaryen who never
became Dragon Riders even more rare than
the riders though were the Targaryen who
were able to hatch
Dragons that is to say the dragon eggs
hatched when they were around them the
way this works is that every Targaryen
child is given a dragon egg and their
cradle at birth most of the time these
eggs never hatch and sometimes
generations would pass with no new
hatchlings while no one knows for
certain what makes someone a dragon
rider or a dragon Hatcher it definitely
seems to be related to genetics
precedent Jacobs made a great theory
video series about this which I'll put a
link to in the description without
rehashing his whole theory it seems
plausible that dragon genes are passed
down through the generations when things
line up right the children will have
dragon powers when the perfect
combination occurs female Targaryen are
born with the ability to hatch dragon
eggs alright so I know this is a lot of
information but thanks for hanging in
there and we finally made it so what we
know Danny is clearly a dragon rider and
a dragon Hatcher since riders only bomb
with one dragon at a time
she should be only able to ride rogue on
one thing about Preston's theory that
adds more credibility to it as that
throughout his theory he was following
the alternate story that R plus L equals
D instead of R plus L equals J the show
however has confirmed R plus L equals J
so the in the R plus L equals D theory
which may still be true in the books
Rhaegar and Lyanna are Danny's parents
instead of Jones following the genetics
in that scenario Liana skin changing
gene would be proxy for a dragon gene
again I won't retell the whole theory
but it makes sense since both dragon
riding and skin changing or a sort of
telepathic connection so if we apply the
idea that Danny had the ability to ride
dragons and hatch dragons to John who
follows the same genetics that we had in
Preston Jacobs theory it's a pretty good
chance that he will be a dragon rider in
simple terms both of his parents have
the
have the right genes to pass on to it's
not a hundred percent like guarantee
because genetics are complicated but it
seems like the odds are in his favor in
the show they don't make much of John
skin changing abilities but it is
mentioned quite a bit in the books in
either way if we accept that the theory
about genetics is even partially true
then the fact that John can slip into
ghosts is a strong indication that he
would be able to come to claim on the
Danish dragons like most things in the
world of the Song of Ice and Fire we
can't know for sure if Jon will be able
to ride a dragon but with the evidence
at hand I would be pretty surprised if
we don't see drawing on a dragon back
when the White Walkers move south past
the wall I also think it's a pretty safe
bet that he'll he'll mount ragle um
since Gregg all's named after his father
that seemed more likely than him just
jumping on vissarion so that's
everything that we know about the
possibility of john being a dragon rider
and i think it's a pretty good case let
me know what you think and make sure
that you do check out preston jacob
series on dragon DNA it's a serious trip
down a dragon hole or rabbit hole i
guess i should say that's worth checking
out so what do you think do you think
jon is going to end up mounting wriggle
and riding them into battle or do you
think that there's some other connection
with this Targaryen blood and for that
matter who do you think's going to ride
vissarion and why like what makes you
think that they're the person that will
be the third head of the dragon please
take a second to like the video if you
enjoyed it and subscribe to my channel
I'm working on a couple other theory of
videos that will be coming out this week
thanks for watching and talk to you soon
and now I leave you with some dragon
glory
you
you